Wow.
Hello?
I like the oriental carpet.
I,
uh,
last time I went around doing a round of talks,
um,
someone had cut and paste into my speaking contract,
something from one of the food network chefs that required an oriental carpet of
certain dimensions and flowers and they had to be all of one particular blue,
not another.
And I didn't know this.
And I kept showing up and people will be like,
hi,
are oriental carbon is a little too small,
like what is wrong with people?
And then I found out that,
uh,
my constant,
but this had happened.
It was horrifying.
So I would show up and go like,
it wasn't me,
it's not me.
I'm not looking at them anyway.
Hey.
Hello.
Hi.
Um,
it's lovely to be here.
And I,
uh,
I've been at the Google,
you know,
the mother ship down in Silicon Valley,
but I've never been here and it's very nice.
So,
um,
the book that I'm running around town promoting these days is called grunt,
the curious science of humans at war and,
um,
which is kind of thrown people a little bit because it seems like sort of,
uh,
dark and somber,
serious topic.
Uh,
and,
and it can be,
but,
but the,
I,
the angle that I cover is,
um,
I'm not writing about a weapons and bombs and strategy.
I kind of leave that to the discovery channel and wire.com and,
uh,
lots of other places that do quite well covering that because,
um,
the,
the human body is always,
that's kind of my bag is a bag of sorts.
So,
uh,
I am covering the sort of,
the human experience of being in combat.
So,
you know,
we were talking about lethal heat and extreme noise and fear and panic and
maggots and flies and diarrhea and all these things you don't necessarily
associate with a military deployment.
Uh,
obviously,
you know,
the combat is what comes to most people's minds.
Uh,
and I got interested in this book.
Um,
I was in India and I was reporting a story for Smithsonian on the hottest Chili,
arguably the hardest,
hottest chili pepper in the world.
There are people who disagree,
but it's called the boots.
Jolokia.
And I was up in Naga land,
the extreme northeast of India,
uh,
reporting this story.
And while he was reporting on the pepper,
someone said,
you know,
the Indian Defense Ministry,
weaponized this pepper.
And I'm like,
I need to know about this.
So,
uh,
I n the science arm or one of the science branches of the Indian Defense
Ministry is in the neighboring state of Assam.
So I went over there,
um,
and talked to folks about the pepper.
As it turns out,
they never deployed the pepper powder because it was prone to mildew.
And,
um,
so that,
uh,
that sort of got set aside.
But while I was there,
I was saying,
well,
what else do you guys do?
And in turn,
they were testing a Leech repellent that day,
uh,
or had been testing.
And I said,
well,
you know,
what's that entail?
And he said,
just scribed going down to the river.
And during monsoon season going down to the river,
rolling up their trousers,
trying on these,
these leacher repels and I thought,
God,
military sciences,
it's kind of Mary Rachel,
kind of not what you would think.
And uh,
I had expected to spend more time with the Indian defense ministry,
but they were,
um,
they had finished up with the leach repelling project and they were not
particularly interested in my poking around there.
So I came back to the u s and pursued it there and assumed that it would be
very,
very difficult to get access.
Uh,
but in fact the,
uh,
the,
office of the Secretary of Defense of the United States has a public affairs
office that deals with books and you can send them a very brief kind of larval
in my case proposal saying,
this is what I'm interested in doing.
And they will sort of give you a kind of a generalized nod of support.
Uh,
w when initially I had thought that it would be a very formal support with like
embossed letters and gold trim and something that I could present,
but in fact just an email that I could very easily have taken out.
The not a,
when they say we yes,
we support,
we're fine with this.
Um,
because as one,
one of the people they're putting,
you know,
Mary Roach writing about this science is really not,
this is not a big concern for us.
Um,
you know,
we're concerned about zero,
dark 30.
I mean,
we have other kids who are you,
I'm just sort of this trifling piffle that they go and do your little science,
diarrhea,
whatever thing you're going to do.
So,
uh,
so,
people were,
were fairly helpful.
It's also,
it's a side of,
uh,
the military's work that doesn't get a lot of,
coverage and some of the work that goes on is,
is,
is pretty cool.
And is,
uh,
you know,
it's nice for those people that get a little bit of a little bit of the
spotlight.
So that's what the book,
that's what the book is about.
So I,
uh,
and I started out,
I started out at the end of the book,
so it's kind of a,
it was kind of strange process.
The first place I went was the armed forces medical examiner system in Dover.
And that's where the military is main mortuary and morgue are.
So,
and when I went there,
I kind of knew that this would probably be the end of the book because it's
pretty,
it's,
it's a little dark or it's just,
you know,
it was a way to kind of wrap up in a way all of the various wanderings of the
book,
they,
the,
the science that I was reporting on there,
it was kind of,
it was pretty amazing.
It was a,
um,
it's called feedback from the field.
And anytime a comes in to the morgue in Dover,
it's given an autopsy.
All bodies are autopsies.
And what's different about these bodies is that all of the life saving equipment
is left in place.
You know,
whether it was a,
you know,
a needle decompression for collapsed lung or a tourniquet and there's some new
technology and tourniquets or,
uh,
an airway device to,
to create a secondary way.
All of that's left in place and it's part of the autopsy.
And then every month there's something called a
combat mortality teleconference in which all the people at the morgue and also
some of the research facilities.
And then folks that for the actual folks oversees that who had done them,
provided the medical care,
the emergency medical care.
All of those people are in this teleconference and they go case by case.
They take seven or eight cases and they sh they have slides and they discuss it
with the aim of identifying things that have been possibly going wrong.
Um,
equipment that isn't working the way the manufacturer thought or it wasn't
placed properly.
Like just getting at the question,
is there anything that could've been done differently,
any way we might have saved this person's life.
So that was a really interesting and of course,
very sobering.
Um,
afternoon.
And one of the things they'd recently figured out there was,
this is kind of just,
just kind of an amazing thing.
You don't really think about,
um,
the,
uh,
number one pastime on these big bases in Afghanistan.
His weight,
it's bodybuilding and uh,
some of the,
the soldiers are there,
their pectorals are so buff,
uh,
that the needle,
the needles they were using for a needle decompression,
which is,
you know,
if you,
uh,
if you've been shot and the air that you're inhaling is ending outside the lung,
it can become difficult to inhale and you can die.
It's like,
I think the second most common cause of fatality in combat anyway.
So the,
um,
they realized the needles weren't making their way through the muscle to the
space that they needed to decompress the pressure.
So that,
cause I'm not sure why this,
why,
you know,
what's going on,
why aren't,
why were these people dying?
And it was,
so it was a,
um,
it was kinda great that,
that they were able to figuring this out,
get the information out there quickly through a teleconference rather than
waiting for somebody to publish a paper,
which is usually,
you know,
kind of the traditional route to,
um,
making that information available.
So,
uh,
so,
but along the way,
you know,
and,
and because it's a Mary Roach from people like,
well,
how's she going to make that funny?
Uh,
how's she going to make it?
What,
how is this book going to work?
So I ended up,
there's a couple of historical chapters that dealt with the,
um,
they were both,
they both had to do with the oss,
which was the precursor to the CIA.
And the oss had some interesting projects and world war two,
including a,
um,
something called who me,
which was a,
um,
a foul smell in a tube that was,
uh,
would be,
the idea would be to distribute it to resistance groups and occupied occupied
countries.
And so motivated citizens could go up behind the German officer say,
and like discretely squeezed this fire this too.
And,
uh,
and spray this.
And it was interesting because the language was all like describing it as a
weapon.
They had specs like it has to be lastingly penetrative.
It cannot,
it has to withstand,
uh,
rain dry cleaning solvents.
It has to be,
um,
uh,
there was a range that it had to cover and it had to do this at 70 different
hedge funds distinct for at least a two hours.
It's 70 degrees Fahrenheit at a certain level.
And their whole thing was sort of documented and they hired out this chemistry
company to figure out,
and there were all these memos that went back and forth about what is a stink,
it's all in the context actually a cause it could,
you know,
if something like butyric acid could smell depending on the cooker and a deli,
it would smell like parmesan cheese.
Uh,
but if you're not in a deli,
it smells like dirty feet.
I think it is,
unless it's vomit anyway,
vomit it.
But so it,
uh,
they were looking for something that would be,
you know,
universally repellent.
So there's all these,
you know,
conversations back and forth.
Oh,
the other,
the other example in this memo about what is a stink well as a trimethylamine
and they said,
which is a fishy smell,
which could be pleasant or unpleasant according to circumstances.
And uh,
trimethylamine is in the tampon world used for testing the powers of deodorant
that of the product that you have.
Anyway,
enough said.
So the,
um,
anyway,
the tubes,
uh,
the tube,
there was all manner of,
uh,
problems with,
um,
backfire.
The weapon was backfiring,
the tubes,
the back that the little led tube,
the crimping wouldn't hold.
There was one guy who at the oss are actually set up a mannequin with a uniform
and he took a box of the tubes and he tried to spray them and there's this very
testy memo saying that most of them had sprayed back at him.
And anyway,
it was just sort of a delightful chapter and,
uh,
military espionage and goings on.
So the,
uh,
the who me was,
this was,
um,
the tradition of nonlethal bad smells is nonlethal weapons has carried on.
Um,
at the Monell chemical senses center where I spent some time there,
the late nineties,
the joint nonlethal weapons directorate commissioned a sensory chemists as in
smell and taste at manel to come up with a universally horrible smell at this
woman.
Pam Dalton went gathering data all over the world.
She had in her suitcase,
she had little bottles labeled a burnt hair,
sewage,
US government,
standard bathroom,
Mel odor,
garbage,
sewage.
And she described when she was,
she was doing a project in South Africa and she thought,
well I could,
you know,
get some more cross cultural data here.
And she had this 15 hour flight and she in her carry on,
she had all the hurts,
smells and she describes getting up from her seat after three hours to go to the
bathroom and standing up.
So her nose is about the height of the overhead login.
She'd be like,
Oh my God,
those are my smells and her smells.
You forgot about the change in pressure and they were leaking.
And so she said to her,
a seatmate,
you cannot open this overhead bin for the entire 15 hours.
Everything will you have at your feet?
That's all we can have.
And that she did this.
Just like,
you know,
when we land,
I know what I'm going to do.
So they land,
she waits for the doors to be open on the plane before she opens the overhead so
that people will go,
Huh,
I guess that's just how it smells here or something.
So this,
um,
uh,
and in the end,
the winner among burnt hair,
which was kind of a stand in for burning body,
you know,
who just thought to be that would be universally abhorred.
But in fact,
when you interviewed some,
you know,
there are all these,
uh,
different cultural groups that had had to say,
is this pleasant,
unpleasant,
wearable?
Is it a wearable?
Sent an edible scent?
And they were for every one of these horrible sense,
there'd be some groups like,
yeah,
all I'd wear that Edward,
I was perfume.
I need that.
Cause he's all out of context,
you know.
So,
uh,
the one that,
that just,
um,
upset and horrified everyone was us government standard bathroom,
Mel Odor,
which you could still get.
And that is something that was devised to,
um,
where,
uh,
come up.
They're trying to come up with a deodorizer for latrines and then World War II,
you know,
some of the open pit latrines,
I'm really nasty,
smell intense.
So they tried to mimic that smell so they could test deodorizing compounds.
So this is a really vital smell.
I have smelled US government standard bathroom now loader and it is pretty bad.
So,
um,
what the,
so that was where they started and then they're very clever and Ronell,
they kinda,
they really know their,
their smells.
They,
they,
what they did for this mallow,
a nonlethal weapon is they came up,
they added a kind of floral,
fruity,
sweet top note to it.
So when you take,
you know,
because when you're presented with an unknown smell,
you take a tentative little whiff and if that top note is nice,
then you do,
it's called the keeper inhale.
So people go,
oh,
this is nice.
And then they'd get this,
this like wall of smell and it tends to stay at,
keeps write something about it.
She said she was the Pam Dalton is the chemist.
She was like,
it,
it keeps re binding to the receptors and you kids stuck in your nose.
And um,
I have in my closet a sample of stench soup that is in a bottle sealed with
paraffin,
double bagged in a box.
And I haven't had the courage to open it.
It's kind of a,
you know,
it's like this mystery box that's just sat there for over a year and I don't
really know,
thought may have a bringing of the Republican National Convention.
Um,
I dunno what I'm going to do with it,
but I will open it somewhere.
I was going to bring,
you know,
I thought maybe like,
oh,
I'll bring it a lot.
Good broken brain to Google.
And then I thought it could get into the,
you know,
the air conditioning is a system,
the ventilation and you guys could be out on the street for days.
So I have to be a little bit careful with my stanch soup.
Uh,
so anyway,
that stench soup.
Um,
but for the most part,
I mean the,
so some of the,
the,
um,
the humor is kind of the historical elements.
And the other thing is just,
I'm such an outsider to the middle of the military culture and it really is a,
a culture,
a foreign culture.
And I've not spent any time in it.
I know my family is not military.
My Dad was 65 when I was born,
so he,
uh,
he enlisted,
he came over on the Lusitania in World War One.
He enlisted in the military,
born in England,
uh,
and he was,
I found his papers at Fort Moultrie.
Um,
but my dad got a hernia in basic training and that's as far that's the
illustrious roach military saga.
So it's not a personal,
uh,
it's not a personal history,
by any means.
I'm very much so,
and I don't really,
I don't know a lot of people in the military.
So it was fascinating to me too,
to be kind of in this world of sort of thrashing around.
Um,
and I would find myself,
I mean sometimes the humor came just from that,
that kind of where I,
I'm really out of my element here.
I was in Djibouti,
which is,
uh,
kind of,
it's north,
that and north African nation above Somalia,
across from Yemen,
which obviously gives you a sense of what goes on there.
It's like,
it's a lot of counterinsurgency,
special operations stuff goes on there and I was on the base.
The,
the special operations to those folks are in a restricted zone that you need
clearance to go into.
Okay.
So I went over there with Captain Mark Rydell,
who is a diarrhea researcher.
He's an MD and he was testing a much faster one dose regimen for um,
for diarrhea,
traveler's diarrhea,
um,
a particular kind of e coli that's fairly common and is pretty nasty.
He was a,
he was over there testing that and the rates of diarrhea,
just among the average deployed soldier mean that in 2003 to four,
so 77% of soldiers and personnel had come down with diarrhea.
40% needed bad enough that they sought medical care.
And 32% had it bad enough that there was a time when they didn't make it to a
bathroom in time.
And if you could imagine a special operations mission that you know,
these are fairly critical,
high risk kind of take out Osama bin Laden style things and if you are hit with
this
sudden extreme urgency,
you can't just go cause someone else cover me because I've got a whole not
feeling well.
So it's,
so it's kind of a matter of national security and if that was my take on it.
So I thought,
okay,
I need to just talk to some of the special operations guys and they're easy to
pick out cause they have beards and no one else there.
Everyone else clean shaven.
They need to fit in with the local population in these villages.
So,
um,
and they only a,
you know,
the public affairs guys like Mary,
I sent out an email for you.
I've already humiliated myself.
They're doing it sort.
It became known as the diarrhea email.
Will somebody please share their stories of diarrhea with our visiting writer?
And nobody will have,
some people did,
but no one from special operations vote.
Oh I will.
So he said,
you know [inaudible] mmm.
So well mark,
Captain Riddle said,
you know,
you're probably a,
you're going to have to talk to him over dinner.
They only come out to eat and train was the public affairs guys.
Go,
guy goes and to steal our women.
Anyway,
so the my only opportunity to talk to these,
um,
individuals who are a little intimidating to someone like me was over was in the
dining facility.
So it created this kind of,
um,
wonderfully awkward scenario of crossing the room to approach this very sort of
stony and omnipotent seeming person eating by himself,
who just kind of looked up at us and said,
I'm done.
And Seamus said,
oh well could ask you just what line of work are you in?
And he said,
I'm leaving.
And he got up to go and I had to jump in and sort of say,
the old mine,
my name is Mary Roach.
I'm working on a book and I actually have,
I wanted to talk to you about diarrhea.
I know that it sounds like a silly,
yeah.
Topic.
And he said,
he looked up and said,
it's not,
you're welcome to sit down.
So it was a very,
it was a very interesting conversation in a very,
yeah.
Um,
unusual reporting challenge.
Anyway.
Um,
so the thing about the book is
one of the,
uh,
one of the reasons I went ahead with this book is because the topics are things
that anybody in the military deals with is a really extreme version of whether
it's overheating or back pain from heavy loads or sleep deprivation or hearing
loss from loud noise.
So it's some that,
you know,
they're all topics.
The science of these topics would be,
you know,
sort of applicable to anybody,
uh,
who has a body and ears and a back.
So,
um,
the hope is that the,
you know,
the,
the middle of the,
the culture of the military is,
is interesting,
but also just the science of,
you know,
like the science of sweat and,
and heat stroke.
Um,
I mean they,
it's a,
it's a big problem,
um,
because the situation that creates heat stroke is this competition for bodily
fluid,
like specifically blood because your,
this,
your sweat is plasma.
It's the clear portion of your blood.
And when you start to overheat,
I mean your body is a machine that wants to be in a set temperature range.
And if you stray from that,
it does what it can to bring it back.
And the first thing it does is it generates sweat.
So all the blood is shunted to your skin and off the,
you know,
the plasma comes out through the sweat glands and then the heat kind of
vaporizes and takes away the heat from your body.
And that's great.
And it's very,
very efficient.
However,
if you're exerting yourself,
if you're carrying a heavy pack and you're running,
especially if you haven't hydrated yourself well,
you have this competition for a limited amount of resources and a certain point,
you know,
that someone's got to go to the muscles and Scott to go to the blood to cool.
You and your body will start to shut down.
Other things,
uh,
that you might not get out of blood to your head that it's why people pass out,
um,
when they're very,
very hot or your gut can start to shut down.
And that leads to a sort of a chain of events that can result in delirium,
coma and then your debt and you're dead.
So it's uh,
um,
the military was trying the um,
medical school,
uh,
use this uniform services,
University of Health Sciences was working on trying to figure out because a lot
of individual differences in how well you acclimate to heat and how badly you
suffer from it.
So the idea was well could we find a blood marker or some sort of,
is there some sort of genetic difference between people?
Can we identify who is really at risk and keep them out of this scenario,
which is a great plan.
And the um,
the,
the work,
it was interesting cause I have the cook box there,
which is a box that they can adjust the heat and humidity and sort of create a
really god awful hot day in the Middle East with a treadmill and a backpack.
I lasted seven minutes out of the hour and a half.
[inaudible] it's,
it's pretty brutal.
And my pack only had 30 pounds,
which is about what the body armor itself would way.
So it's,
it's unbelievable how,
um,
how fit and how these people are,
what they endure.
Um,
and,
but like anything,
you know,
that the something that seems like it'd be a good answer.
It's a little tough because
I'm s what happens?
You take people out of the things like,
okay,
this guy,
obviously he,
you know,
we've been able to identify these people are not going to farewell and extreme
heat,
so let's hold them back.
And then,
so the people who are fit ended up doing more than their fair share.
They're the only ones you can call in to do a really hard job.
And so they push themselves and then collapse.
So,
um,
it,
it's just,
it's just really hard.
And the,
yeah,
the,
there's an environmental medicine unit at Natick labs that has a mannequin that
sweats that they figure out like these sweat prediction equations where,
you know,
give me how much,
how many miles,
how hard is it,
how much are they carrying,
what's the body armor?
And you plug it all into a formula and it tells you this is how much water per
person to carry.
So they're trying to get it dialed down to a science.
But ultimately it's,
you,
you know,
when you get into the real world of a,
of a mission,
there's always five or six things nobody counted on and you can't,
it's just,
it's just really hard to hand someone a formula that's going to solve all their
problems.
And the soldiers are like,
God,
there was scientists,
you know,
they do,
these rules that these guys and air conditioned offices come up with.
So there's kind of a tension between the soldiers and the scientists,
but they're all trying to do their job.
Um,
anyway,
so it was a,
you know,
I,
and the one,
one thing I wanted to do for the book,
I initially had planned to embed this was um,
when we were,
there was still stuff going on in Afghanistan and I was going to embed my,
I initially had an idea I wanted to embed with the fourth Marine Corps dental
battalion just because I really that they are whole concept of a Marine Corps
dental battalion just really appealed to me.
As I said this I own notion of these guys parachuting in with a little picks
smocks and um,
of course that's not the case but,
but anyway,
and they are like,
yeah,
well we're not going anywhere.
Um,
thanks for your interest.
So the Marine Corps dental battalion was off the list sadly,
but I still like to talk about the fourth Marine Corps dental battalion just
cause there's a dental battalion.
Yeah.
I'm Marine Corps to dental battalion.
Similarly,
I want to,
I at one point I thought it would be,
um,
because my editor,
of course it's like special operations.
Can you,
can you go out with a special operations team?
And like kind of think that's classified stuff,
but I'll try.
So I called the Special Operations Command Public Affairs Office and I thought,
okay,
I know I'll cover,
I'll,
what about,
because they have their own weather command there.
They were on whether people,
cause that's a big,
if you're flying in somewhere or however you're getting them mean whether it's
important and it's a critical element.
But I could just imagine if you made it,
I mean it's a very,
yeah,
just very elite group.
And if you made it into special operations and then you get to brag about that
doing,
I'm special operations,
special operations,
weather command.
So I thought that would be interesting.
And like these folks that would do an interesting take on the whole thing.
And I explained that to pub to public affairs guy and he said,
yeah,
that's just not gonna.
That's not gonna happen.
It's,
it's classified.
And I actually,
I actually said to him,
um,
but I'm only gonna ask questions about whether,
so I won't actually,
I won't pay any attention to anybody else's what they're doing.
A No,
no.
So,
uh,
so there were,
there were some,
some walls that were thrown up,
understandably and my efforts to report this book.
But,
um,
I made my way onto a,
uh,
a,
a ballistic missile submarine,
the USS Tennessee,
which was a fascinating place to be.
They were trying out there have a serious issue with sleep deprivation.
Um,
the,
most of the guys at that time had been averaging around four hours sleep.
It's kind of not what you want on a vessel that is powered by a nuclear reactor
and carries a 20 some trident missiles.
So they were trying out a different watch cause they kind of,
because you have a submarine is a isolated from the normal cues of day and
night.
You can,
they thought was,
well maybe we can muck with circadian rhythm and create a different length of
day,
thereby making things more productive.
But in fact,
you had a situation where they might've been a little less sleep deprived,
but it was like flying to Paris every day is how someone put it.
Cause they were,
the circadian rhythm was just off.
Their body rhythm was off with the clock.
Uh,
so they were,
they were trying something,
it'd be a moving it back onto a circadian friendly time schedule so that that's
what was going on on the USS Tennessee.
It took me a year and a half to get on there.
Not because anybody was saying no,
just because it was very hard to find somebody who's,
who had the authority to say yes.
So you get a lot of it seems okay to me,
but I'm not the one who could say yeah.
So you'd kind of get bounced around the um,
the Djibouti trip,
I think there are probably 60 or so emails flying around over the span of three
weeks to just try to like go with the diarrhea researcher to Camp Lemon.
Yay.
And,
and,
and the,
the navy public affairs person was like,
it seems fine to me.
I don't even know is it's Centcom,
is it?
AFRICOM is a joint Horn of Africa.
Is that the Pentagon?
I have no idea who to ask.
I don't know who can sign off on it.
So it was like,
and finally it came down to that guy Seamus on the ground and camp lemon,
Yay.
Who had seen all these emails pinging around and finally said,
he said,
cause I asked him,
how did you make this happen?
He said,
well,
you know,
certain point,
I thought,
this is not like diarrhea.
You can't just hydrate and wait for it to go away.
Uh,
we're going to,
somebody has to,
somebody has to do something.
So he met me,
I went into the base commander's office and I said,
do you care if this woman comes here to talk about diarrhea with people?
And he was like,
I don't care.
So they should,
they said,
yes,
that's fine.
So weeks of,
you know,
formally petitioning the wrong person over and over and over.
And in the end it was just the guy on the ground.
Sorry,
I have a little bit of a lost Lou.
I've been talking a lot lately,
so I should probably sort of wind it down and take,
um,
take questions from any,
from anybody who has questions or if you wanted me to talk about any of the
other,
um,
any of the other subjects.
You know,
in the,
in the book there's,
um,
I talked also about,
uh,
genital injuries,
which is something we've been seeing lately.
And,
uh,
for two reasons as there's been that the bombs have gotten bigger and also the
emergency medical care and medical evacuations have gotten better and faster.
So,
um,
bigger injuries and more people surviving them.
It used to be if there was a bomb big enough to damage the pelvic region rather
than just blow off your foot,
you didn't survive.
And now these guys are surviving.
So there's,
um,
interesting reconstructive work.
Some of it,
uh,
some of it coming out of a cooperation with the transgender community,
which who build penises all the time.
Like,
what do you need to know?
So anyway,
um,
so there's that.
And,
uh,
Oh I,
lots of other fun topics,
but I'd be happy to,
to talk about any questions people have or you know,
by what we're about.
Any of my other books or,
so you do a lot of research.
How much actually makes it into the book and how many of these gems are just
left on the floor?
Oh well I write everything down because I don't,
when I go somewhere I don't really know what the chapter's about quite I cause I
haven't met these people.
I don't really know what's going to happen.
So I'm just writing everything down.
I would say 0.01% of what I write down.
I actually use,
it's insane.
It's so much just stuff that,
and I'll go back and look at a notebook.
I don't eat,
I have no idea what I was even writing down.
Um,
so no gems,
the gems?
No,
the gems go in the book.
In fact,
when I,
like when I go on a reporting trip,
I go back to my,
um,
to my room and I go through my notebook and I have a system where if it looks
like a promising something somebody said or something that was interesting and
I'll circle it.
And if it's really good,
I'll circle it and put three stars,
next one,
two or three stars.
We have this rating system,
then I pull that stuff out into a transcript and then I print that out and then
I go through and circle stuff in there.
So,
and I moved the really good stuff to the top,
kind of just like,
this is the good shit.
This is going to go in somehow.
And that actually influences how I shaped the chapter.
Like they're,
you know,
if there's a scene that I,
that is really great that seems like it'll be really fun to read,
you know,
all figured out now what,
what's the order of these two or three scenes?
So identify the scenes and then quotes and,
but most of it,
yeah,
most of it just,
and on that,
when I was on the submarine at one point I was interviewing someone and I,
and,
and um,
something was said over the intercom that was classified and the,
uh,
the ship's commanding officer said,
I'm really sorry,
you're going to have to delete that.
And I said,
it's a,
it's an a,
it's an MP three file.
I can't go in.
I mean,
you guys probably could,
you can't go in and just delete a word.
Uh,
and he said,
well,
you have to,
you know,
you're either gonna have to delete the whole file or I guess I could transcribe
it.
I'm like,
so this guy,
this guy,
he's so busy,
he's got so many,
so much on his plate and this annoying journalists do there for four days out at
sea.
He's like,
I kept going by his state.
He was a little state room and he's hunched over a computer and it was the most
beautifully transcribed.
Every word written out spelled perfectly,
you know,
Mary Roach Colon.
And then,
you know,
it was like a,
uh,
like a screenplay,
whereas when I type it,
it's just,
you could barely figure out,
I abbreviate every word and um,
anyway,
so that's kind of my haphazard procedure.
Yeah.
Hi,
I was very interested to hear you talk about the autopsies in the beginning of
your remarks.
Picked her because in the nonmilitary world,
a lot of doctors are concerned that they're not doing enough.
Autopsies are not learning enough from their mistakes or the problems.
Do you know anything about how the information might flow?
Like do the military doctors write papers or data summaries from what they
learned in their autopsy work?
They,
uh,
I think they do write papers.
I mean they do the mortality costs though that conference just to get the
information back to the emergency,
the medics and the emergency room people.
But I think they do.
Yeah,
I do go on and write papers based on what they're learning from autopsy
autopsies,
like hospital autopsies.
That's an interesting realm.
Like I know the medical examiner in the bay area.
Of course I do.
We go have lunch and she'll go,
oh,
I've got a decomp today.
Do you want to come over?
I'm like,
Hey,
not so much before lunch.
No.
Um,
and she said there are some like that.
there is sometimes,
I mean it didn't give you the specifics were but like,
you know,
hos there might be pressure on the metal cause laminar medical examiner not to
find negligence,
which would,
that was upsetting to me like that the,
well the whole idea with an autopsy is to get at the truth of why did what
happened.
Know I probably,
that's not a regular occurrence,
but that was sort of disconcerting.
So I think there's some politics behind the prevalence of,
of autopsy.
Um,
well,
so it's,
it's tends to be done.
Yeah.
In,
you know,
when the cause is an obvious,
when it seems to be no suicide or homicide is suspected.
But there's lots of,
you know,
like people die in hospitals and the family wants to know you can,
you can get a private,
you can call 1-800-AUTOPSY and they drive up in a van.
No,
there,
there are,
there are actually you can,
you can contract someone to do an autopsy.
So there's a,
that would be an interesting realm to explore.
I don't know that much about it or whether I have even answered your question.
Thank you.
Hi.
Um,
I am a huge fan of your box there.
Oh,
thanks.
[inaudible] very educational and it in,
I have not read grant yet.
Done.
Very Sad.
And a lot of the things that you've spoken about are the physical,
the smell.
Yes.
The bodies.
Um,
do you touch your,
have you touched on the mental side of things and technology and innovation in
that space?
Um,
I was going to,
when after the Fourth Marine Corps Dental battalion turned me down,
um,
the,
I had planned and got permission to embed with the chaplains core because they,
they were,
you know,
I wanted to cover,
um,
PTSD or,
or not PTSD,
but just specifically emotional issues and how a variety of them like dealing
with,
you know,
a death in a unit or whatever comes up.
Um,
and the chaplain and the chaplain's assistant who has a weapon and covers for
the chaplain,
they go out on missions with you with a unit.
They early,
um,
uh,
which I didn't realize,
I hadn't realized that,
that I thought,
I thought they stayed back on base and had an office with people would come to,
but they'll actually go out like on a route clearance mission or whatever it is.
So there that they can offer this empathy.
I wasn't interested in that in,
in the religious elements so much is their ability to empathize because they've
kind of been through similar hardships and that fascinated me and I was really
disappointed.
I was approved by the u s but then I saf,
which is the coalition umbrella organization said no because it's the draw down
and we don't have hardly any journalists and I'm no,
and I think it was more like,
hey,
you didn't ask us who says you can go?
He like,
somehow he saw an email.
It's like,
hey,
did you didn't talk to me?
I don't know.
Do you know what they say?
ISF stands for and I suck at fighting.
That's my little dig at Isat fraternity.
No,
now there I didn't even,
I stopped being international.
I didn't even know what does it,
what does it eve,
what does ICF even stand for?
International?
It's those guys,
the overseers.
It's the coalition.
But anyway,
um,
I had,
because I didn't really have a narrative that,
um,
there wasn't a,
I didn't find another way in that would afford kind of,
I like,
I like to have a sort of a scene in a setting and things.
So,
and I'm usually not doing,
I think I had a chapter in packing from ours that had to do with sort of unique,
uh,
psychological components of being in space.
And I had,
I had planned to do that but didn't end up.
And there's this,
there's a lot of coverage of that as well,
that other people I think have done a nice job with.
Yeah.
Cool.
Thank you.
I'm looking forward to reading it.
Hi.
Uh,
after spending so much time,
um,
in your research,
did you find your opinions related to the military?
It's command structure.
It's politics,
the soldiers,
their lifestyle or their worldview.
Did,
did you find your opinion's changing on that at all?
And what was kind of the before and after that?
Well,
but the,
the before was that I had a very,
I had this view of the military as this sort of monolithic entity,
which is the more time you spend in that realm,
the more you see how fractured it is.
There's not just the different branches of the military,
but there's,
you know,
there's the policy people in the Pentagon and then there's the scientists and
the medical people and the civilians who work.
And so it's,
so it became really hard to have a opinion.
Um,
I ended up having a tremendous amount of respect for the researchers to do this
work,
you know,
which is going toward trying to make this God awful experience somewhat more
tolerable and survivable.
Um,
though those guys,
those people,
a lot of them were women actually in the book or were great.
And so that,
that's the main world I inhabited and I didn't,
so I didn't,
I don't really have a,
I mean,
my views on the larger entity of war and military policy,
et Cetera,
have not changed,
but that,
that didn't change.
Excellent.
Yeah.
I was interested to hear,
you're talking about the circadian rhythm stuff on the submarines.
Yeah.
Especially because since I read,
uh,
you know,
I think bonk and stuff for the,
the first two books I read,
I've been wondering if you were ever going to do a book specifically about
sleep.
Yeah.
You know what?
People have suggested that.
Did I cut you off or was that yours?
Oh,
yeah.
Yeah.
Oh,
do you think,
you know,
sleep well,
two things are going on.
My editor at ww Norton just edited a book called Dreamland,
I think on sleep,
the science of sleep,
but more than that,
um,
because it's an dreaming and sleep.
It's an internal state,
a lot of,
uh,
I'm trying to imagine what would be the scene in the setting.
It'd be like chapter after chapter of a guy on a bed with electrodes asleep.
So it was kind of hard to you then.
You know how when you tell your spouse or partner your dream and they're like
instantly like,
shut up,
it's so boring.
I don't,
please don't tell me your dream.
Um,
so trying to describe,
I mean not that it would be entirely about dreaming,
but it felt a little confining in terms of the,
the,
the color and the scenes and the kind of the,
the narratives that would bring the research to life.
So for that reason,
but I,
it is a good time and I have given it thought.
Yeah.
Cool.
Well thank you.
Yup.
Hi.
Thank you for coming.
My,
my wife was very jealous that she wasn't able to come see your,
your,
one of your favorite authors.
Have there been any themes for books that you've started pursuing and then
abandoned because they didn't actually bear enough fruit and if so,
what were they?
Yeah,
there was one that,
um,
there was one idea I had for a book that morphed into packing for Morrison,
but originally,
um,
this,
this guy I knew from way back when had gotten a job in Galveston at the bed rest
facility at um,
that,
that connected to NASA [inaudible] where are they are they're studying um,
muscle wasting and bone loss from,
from being in weightlessness because your body to kind of just takes apart your
muscles or we don't need these,
we're going to take them apart.
There's a lot of,
a lot of bone loss and muscle wasting and to at the analog for that,
that's this simulation is to have people lie in bed slightly head down and not
get up for three months and um,
be they're paid like $17,000 or something so that world and thought,
wow,
the whole human Guinea pig world seemed kind of interesting and bizarre.
Um,
but yeah,
I talked to my age and he's like,
it seems like it would be a little repetitive and there is there enough variety
to widen me.
A lot of people are testing drugs,
pharmaceuticals.
That is an interesting world,
but that has been covered a fair amount.
And so again,
it was a situation where I didn't think there was,
I didn't know that there was enough variety or my agent didn't think that there
would be quite enough variety to the landscape to make it,
um,
to make it a go.
So,
so I folded that into packing for Mars.
Uh,
you do a lot of traveling for your research and uh,
it seems some,
some places kind of recur from,
from book to book.
Yeah.
And I was wondering,
uh,
on any given trip,
how many different projects are you working on at a time?
Okay.
Uh,
on any given trip,
often just one chapter.
Oh yeah,
the,
well,
the India trip,
I was traveling with a friend who was doing some charitable work for a
organization called books and water that tries to,
or the puts in a wells in villages and portable libraries.
So we,
I was traveling with her and then I,
she was going to be in Nagaland and I was like,
Naga land,
I've never heard of it.
So I looked it up,
heard about the chili pepper contest and pitched that.
So I was doing two things there.
But usually when I travel somewhere,
I'm,
I'm only doing one,
uh,
one chunk of research.
Yeah.
And here I was envisioning some huge master plan.
You know what,
I'd love that,
but I can I,
yeah,
it never works out that way.
It never,
it's always,
and sometimes they'll be like,
oh,
I've got to go to London for this.
And then six weeks later there's another thing,
you know,
so I can't combine them because it's all their schedule,
not mine.
So I'm constantly sort of being buffeted here and there by researcher schedule's
good things get pushed back and delayed and I,
so I,
uh,
you know,
so I never go on a vacation myself cause I'm like,
Whoa,
that cadaver project,
when come through next month.
Oh,
it's been delayed,
you know,
so I'm constantly not,
and I don't do a lot of talks outside of book tour for that reason as well
because I just,
I may need to up and go quickly.
Yeah.
I wish anyone else.
All right then.
Thank you.
Thanks a lot.